so I'm here I'm amber is born in
sergeant I am here to report on my
progress from last time when I was here
at strangely where I presented an
optional type system for closure called
type closure and this is really a
preliminary look at the journey from
create from turning this from an
optional type system to a gradual type
system and if none of those words make
sense then you're in the right place
because I'm gonna explain everything so
yeah here we were at Strange Loop 2014
we had an optional type system and this
is the lofty goal of a gradual type
system and I don't know how many dots
are in this dotted line yet but we're
getting there but this is the kind of
the context of the talk I'm going to be
explaining or some of the the dotted
dotted line parts that I've currently
implemented what's left and why it's
important so first off what is gradual
what is optional typing sorry well I
like to think of optional typing as
combining these two worlds of untyped
and typed lands so you can you can you
can understand an untyped compilation as
kind of following this this compilation
pipeline so in closure we have a reader
and then an analyzer and then an emitter
but basically the point to get from this
is that there is no type checker here
but in type code for example in type
closure we have a deviation into the
type system so what is an optional type
system
well optional types allow us to swap
back and forth at will between these two
worlds and kind of as soon as we buy
into this we we have a few intrinsic
restrictions one is that the runtime
cannot depend on the output of type
checking because if it did then we we
wouldn't be able to swap if we swapped
and then our program wouldn't run
anymore then that isn't really my
definition of an optional type system
and really in practice this is like a
linter if you've ever used court types
it's kind of like you write some some
untyped code you annotate it and then
you use this
specific function check NS to check it
like a linter and you can use this this
function in your unit test or continuous
integration so type closure is really
the sum of closure the language and an
optional type system so here's some
examples of of type closure so these two
lines the first one isn't as a Vienna
tation and this is Mitch you can think
of this as machine check documentation
in the same way you can think of any
type system as giving you machine jack
documentation so there's an expectation
that the square function is an intent we
write some normal closure code the
second line is compiled normally in
through via the the closure compiler and
yet we verify it's an intent so closure
programmers like to use heterogeneous
Maps which is basically like an
immutable map which is which has keyword
values keyword keys map to known values
so here we have a function day that kind
of takes this this map that has a day
key and we take out the day and just
return it and type closure can kind of
follow this another interesting thing
about type closure is that it in the
same way that closure interacts nicely
with Java type closure also interacts
nicely with Java and it in a sense kind
of enhances the the types that Java
gives you so we have non nullable types
for example you can see here we have a
union of nil and string as the return
type of this particular function so that
basically means that I should clarify
that nil is exactly Java's null there's
nothing more to it it's just another
name for now but since we have a null
type that basically means everything
else is non nullable so what this get
parent function really means is that
it's passing in an instance of Java IO
file as in a non-volatile instance and
returning a possible possibly null
instance of strength and you can see
type closure actually is proving that
this particular code doesn't throw a
null pointer exception so
for example if you get parent on nil
it'll blow up spectacularly but sigh
pleasure prevents this sort of error and
if the input was Nala bêlit would
complain and also notice that we can't
claim that the return type of this is
non nullable because Java just the Java
type signature just doesn't allow for
that kind of fine grained type so
closure programmers like to use
conditional control flow to direct their
programs in particular directions and
usually its type based so there's a lot
of information that a type system can
learn just by analyzing an if statement
for example here we have the safe
increment function which really just
takes a nullable integer and tests if
it's a number if it is a number then we
increment it otherwise we do something
else and if this if statement wasn't
here type closure would complain and say
something like expected in got nil
basically saying that Inc cannot take an
the null pointer and then I'll reference
sorry so let's combine some of the
things we've learned so far we have
unions and H maps well there's nothing
stopping us from combining these we have
this handy type alias mechanism here we
define a recursively defined type alias
that is basically a very small abstract
syntax tree representation we have a
composite composite node which is a
dunno that has several expressions
inside of it and that's the first line
of the Union and a leaf node value and
you can see we can distinguish between
these two things by the OP key so if you
look up the OP cane it's a do then it
must have an expose if you look up at
the OP key and it's a vowel it must have
a Val entry so the way the closure
program is usually dispatch on H maps of
this kind of type board just Maps in
general is with a multi method so rather
than elaborately explaining well no this
will be elaborate I let the elaboration
begin
so we're going to pass it some abstract
syntax tree that I've created and you
the first thing you should think of when
you're writing a multi method is what
you want to dispatch on and I said the
way to distinguish between the two
abstract syntax tree nodes is with the
OP key so the second read R is basically
where you write that information so we
dispatch on the OP key well what if it's
a do well we go to this def method and
what I'm actually tracing is the way
that type of closure reasons about this
control flow so type closure is actually
following this as well so it's a do node
so therefore the Xmas key if we get it
out that must be a vector of expressions
therefore if we sum the recursive calls
of this of these expressions then we can
call map of F over this vector of
expressions and it will all be well
types and we get 42 because it's 30 plus
12 okay so that was kind of a recap of
everything that I presented last year
but optional typing is really all the
rage right now the last five or six
years they've been popping up all over
the place
for example Facebook's hack is a
optional type system for PHP it allows
you to mix and match typed and untyped
PHP in the same file or in any way you
please javascript has many stories for
optional typing one is dot which kind of
is an optional type system for Java
JavaScript sorry but it's also really a
language in itself but flowing type
scripts really do have the the same
syntax as JavaScript except it adds
annotations right and type scripts it's
recently moving into some pretty cool
directions it's adding union types and
intersection types and this sort of flow
control that I demonstrated before with
conditional statements and finally my
play is an optional type system for
Python which is contributed back to
Python by by inspiring it to
particular syntax for optional type
optional type annotations so for example
the three JavaScript optional type
systems have different ways of
annotating things but if if another
optional type system was made for Python
it would use the same syntax so type
closure in practice I presented a use
case last year circle CI so they in 2013
they started using type closure and two
years later they gave me access to their
to the type code and I gathered these
metrics and they're very interesting
actually over a two-year trial we there
were 87 typed namespaces and the next
three dopeboyz kind of justify all the
features that I that I just presented to
you so there were 105 Java interactions
around 300 hates Maps or heterogeneous
maps and 11 multi methods with 89 def
methods in other words if I if type
closure didn't support these things but
none of these things would type check
but kind of it's not that big of a
victory because if you look at this last
line only 20% of those 87 namespaces
were were checked in other words there
were so many idioms that weren't
supported by type closure that for one
reason or another the circle CI dad's
decided to not type check particular
functions because it was just taking too
much effort excuse me
so I'll take questions at the end thank
you
so yeah about a month ago they they very
politely emailed me and told me hey
we're we're thinking of not using type
pleasure anymore and I encouraged them
to release a blog post post mortem and
luckily here it is it's a few days old I
recommend reading it it's very very
informative at the current state of type
closure I've actually worked on the
circle CI code base myself and I vouch
for everything that's that's written
here but in the interest of time I'm
going to distill the three nine points
in the post mortem one is that oh my
type checking is so slow and yeah I
apologize for the actually I don't want
to think about the hundreds of program
at how as I've wasted I'm very I'm very
sorry but I made a decision in 2012 that
it's kind of annoying having a rebel be
in an inconsistent state at if it's
dealing with run time values imagine if
your apples in an inconsistent state at
the run time but also at the compiled at
the the static type system level right
so I was like okay let's let's
completely rule out that case by every
time you type check a namespace wipe the
entire slate clean transitively
and check everything two things one
thing I've had very very few complaints
that typed that core tight gets in
inconsistent states the other thing is
that if you have 86 namespaces they will
all be checked again so there's some
middle ground to be to be looked over
alright so I kind of alluded to this the
second problem this in complete support
for closure idioms and kind of attribute
it to the the fact that 80 percent of
that code was not type checked which is
which is bad and there's this third
point which I brought up last year I
have seen third-party annotations
floating around more than I had last
year so I kind of made a an appeal to
the good strange loopers in the audience
if they could release their type
annotations and some of them did but
unfortunately in circles the ice case
every single third-party annotation they
had was written by themselves so in
other words they had to reverse-engineer
all of their dependencies and that sucks
but for this talk I'm just going to
concentrate on the second point this
this problem that we have 80% of code
that's unchecked and I'm assuming it's
because the ink plays support for
closure idioms so here's the pitch
there's this concept called gradual
typing and without much without many
changes to
the two the way that you would type
check code right now you could check the
80% that's left not at compile time but
at run time then gradual typing also
incorporates kind of these three ideas
that you can check things at compile
time you can check things at run time
and you can also sanely mediate the the
interaction between these two worlds or
types and untyped worlds so what is
gradual typing exactly well in a
sentence gradual typing forces all code
to respect static invariants and I will
show you an example right now so here's
a static statically typed Square
function that we saw at the at the top
of the show there was it's an int int
function and if you notice on the on the
right there's a a type sorry left I
practiced that no that was I did say
left in my practice so we have two
invitations and lo and behold they
return the same answer and this is this
is great if these return different
answers would be in trouble so it gets
interesting when we violate the static
assumptions so in in type code on the
Left there's a static type error and it
actually tells you the the point where
it went wrong and it's exactly
right here what happens on the untyped
side well we get this null pointer
exception now if my memory serves me
correctly I've gone to many conferences
around the world and fled like this and
said type closure prevents null pointer
exceptions in type code what is
happening well there's a stack trace
that's the null pointer exception that
ends in in type code so this kind of
reveals the way that we speak about
soundness results in in optional typing
we forget the rest of the world exists
we basically yeah so gradual typing
doesn't do that it it embraces the world
it allows you to
to talk to type code without this kind
of threat of null pointer exceptions and
bad things so the only difference for
this example this is gradual typing and
on the on the right here we have a an
untyped namespace that is managed by the
gradual type system hypothetical gradual
type system the type closure provides
and look it gives you a nice error this
is a runtime error and what's actually
happening is that the this kind of gold
ring around the untyped code kind of
signifies this language mediator that I
was alluding to which I will clarify but
basically it in this case we're
hijacking the compilation of the untyped
code and this square new here and we are
compiling it to something that will
guarantee that it cannot violate the
assumptions of the typed code so here we
were casting the the int the argument to
be in integer but this is where it's
going to fail before it yeah it's going
to point exactly to that nil and that
that cast was the the reason why so
there's another interesting feature of
gradual typing and it kind of answered
this this weird question that optional
typing provides is how much type code
will have to write before I can prevent
null pointer exceptions for example that
there's a all need to be type can it be
some of it on types well here's a
scenario so that the the top namespace
number one depends on two and three
which depends on four so let's say we
converted the top one to type code so
can this interact with untyped code sure
it's dependent on two untyped things so
we saw before that you know this is a
problem null pointer exceptions will
happen so okay well let's let's let's
make it typed okay can this what happens
here okay well we're in the same
situation and
God we've typed the world.this this
isn't very sustainable but somewhat
vacuously typed invariance cannot be
violated because there are no there
there's no untyped code to violate the
the typed assumptions gradual typing has
this pretty cool feature where if we
have the same situation we have a
language we can kind of pick a point
where we want to to assert everything at
run time instead of arbitrarily picking
how much untrusted or trusted code that
we have we instead use the language
boundary for the ninety ace is two and
three we actually check at that point
the interactions between typed and
untyped and the interesting thing is
here we're done
typed invariants cannot be violated
because there's no direct path from type
to untap that doesn't go through a
language boundary that's managed by the
the language mediator okay so i've been
saying this language mediator a lot
let's explain what that is
so is this cool gradual type system for
racket called typed racket and here's
kind of a pictorial way of how it works
so we have we have racket on the right
and type racket on the left with this I
think it is green I'm sorry I'm so ever
created this racket logo I'm sorry I
destroyed it but type racket needs a
logo so there were three parties here
actually this type racket racket and
there's this line actually the line is
very important it's it's yellow it's the
the language boundary that I've been
talking about so you take racket code
for example there you can if you are
typed racket you could say give me some
untyped code so what's going to happen
the language boundary is going to wrap
it in runtime checks such that the
static invariants are upheld
so for example be the opposite direction
if type racket wanted to export code
well that also adds runtime checks
actually this direction isn't as
intuitive why do we need haven't we
already checked this green blob all
right isn't it type checks well it once
we go in this direction it's more that
we don't want bad things getting in like
we don't want things that violate the
invariants getting in and the opposite
we don't we don't trust the thing that's
inside so we want bad things getting out
or unsound things so for tight bracket
they've they have some justifications
for why they use gradual typing one of
the main ones is that they had this
suite of unsafe operations which
segfault if you get it wrong so if you
if you rewrite your programmer you're
not quite sure if if a particular
invariant will be violated well you
probably shouldn't use this unsafe
operation but it turns out if you use
this language mediator the holy line
then all of these optimizations are safe
because once you once you go over this
way once you cross the typed land you
can you can trust untyped code and once
you cross to untie planned you can
you're guaranteed that nothing bad can
get in and cause a seg fault and this is
other notion of blame which is basically
a way to track error messages and you
can imagine it well if we can cross the
language boundary once why not do it
twice why not do it three times and at
some point let's assume something
something bad happens and it blows up
who's to blame well there are these
mechanisms that that come with the
language mediator that allow us to track
exactly what the source of the error
instead of the symptom as we saw before
the source of passing Mills Square was
passing null to square it wasn't passing
note to multiplication so what if I done
so what have we done actually use excuse
me what have we done in type closure so
far in in in the direction of gradual
typing
well again here we were in 2014 we had
an optional type system and I've been we
have been working slowly towards gradual
typing in that we are integrating more
into the compiler and here are two
features that have been requested since
2012 and they're here
so one optimization that's kind of
obvious is that well we have this static
type checker why don't we use it to
interact with the other type system in
closure type ins unfortunately
previously you've had to write both type
hints and Static types even though it's
so obvious which type hints need to be
well it seems obvious to someone who's
not a type checker that that that these
particular type hints are relevant in
particular places but also remember it
was an optional type system so that
runtime cannot depend on the the type
checker so it's kind of didn't really
fit but now we're moving towards gradual
typing which is very much more
integrated in the compilation process it
actually makes sense and there's also a
type treble which looks like this
basically what you do is you add a
little bit of metadata to your type
namespace this quarter typed keyword and
then you just use the repple and it's
type checks and you can see you've got a
you know an inferred type for this type
and if you if you pass a nil to Inc for
example you get a static type error and
the the form is then not evaluated so
basically a normal type repple that
should have been there a long time ago
but I think the reason why this wasn't
here is because n repple won't blame it
on your Apple I'll say I didn't know
that n R Apple existed but if you want
to use this download and ripple or line
again and put in this middleware and you
can have this type r apple as well so as
part of this type repple
not everyone uses the repple all the
time clearly we put code in files so it
would be nice if we actually just
required
file and it would just type check it so
for example here we have a type
namespace where we again being a dead
horse here
don't pass nil to Inc but if we were
required this namespace we get a null
pointer exception and that's basically
because we're not passing it to the type
checker but if we put in that
Lonnegan middleware and have a bit of
metadata that caught or typed it will
any any call to require will basically
feed every every form into the type
triple so I was talking before about
transitively read checking everything
well it turns out the way that this is
implemented it fixes this automatically
because the way it's implanted is
basically at monkey patches closure dot
cord slash load and basically
programmers use a require to to load
code and that that subsequently calls a
load but it only calls load if it's if
it hasn't been cased before so since
type checking has been monkey passion to
load then whenever you if you have your
editor opening your press run it will
only check the transitive dependencies
if it hasn't been compiled yet so in
other words what you are expecting in
the first place but you know we'll see
how terrible having two levels of
inconsistent ripples are but I really do
like the the current the current way
that type closure uses it redefines
everything and I'll definitely I think
this is a good default not having two
minute waits for one character changes
yeah
and I'll leave in the other one as an
option and we have this idea of type
hints as I said before we're actually
using static types to to inform the
closure compiler how to resolve type
hints and I'm just kind of showing off a
bit here
you can see where we're at
we're getting the parent of a file but
really it's it's a type any but then
type closure figures out that it's an
instance of file right so then it you
know it knows it's it's a method pretty
trivial but I thought it was Chronicle
anyway so what's next we've seen the
type rebel automatic type hints that's
kind of what the last six months is has
given us here are some immediate
problems with implementing gradual
typing so we have this idea of proxying
which I'll explain and how to implement
this wholly yellow line in the middle
and both directions being just as
effective as one another so again we saw
the way that type rocket uses the the
language mediator is that wraps code in
something and that something is often a
proxy and a proxy allows you to
basically intercept if you were going to
proxy some sort of objects you would you
might want to intercept a method call
for example you might want it to only
return integers so the problem with
writing proxies in closure is that
almost everything that we care about is
declared final so good luck sub classing
it kind of inherit from final class so
this was this is this is a problem and I
if you have any ideas please please let
me know I'd love to hear you from hear
from you but here's a good reason why
you might want to use a proxy in the in
a real in real situation say we have
this protocol which is like an interface
that has a get X and get Y and as it
describes the methods of a point then we
have a concrete implementation of a
point that implements this get get X and
get Y methods and then we wanted to
create a proxy that intercepted the
these three methods right and you can
imagine this point class is coming from
untyped to type so we want to actually
verify that it's returning the correct
thing yeah and again it's the same error
I cannot inherit from final class how
did racket fix this well it turns out
the people who
type racket also work on the racket
virtual machine so they they changed the
racket virtual machine and added
chaperones and impersonators which are
different variations on proxies
unfortunately this is what we're stuck
with to to big locks I made I have a
better chance of getting unlocking
closure but I have no aspirations to
really try JVM forget about it and
here's this yellow line again the
language mediator this is kind of one of
the next things we're going to do is
figure out the details of how to
implement this so for example we have a
types namespace on the left and we're
importing some untyped code so you can
see the untyped code by its name you
might think it's an increment function
but really it just returns a string so
so who wrote this function it's terrible
but the naive typed programmer says okay
it's an increment incrementing function
it must be an int int so we use it on
the next line we increment 41 okay well
it crosses language boundary now the we
have a contract or probably a proxy
around this this particular function
that checks there's an int int and
something bad is going to happen we're
going to blame something we could either
blame the the poor typed programmer for
assuming that this Inc function actually
does what it what it seems to to
advertise or we could blame the untyped
the untyped code for having a bad
implementation okay so just to wrap up
this is where we were a year ago at
strangely 2014 we had an optional type
system everything kind of worked like a
linter and from there over the last six
six or 12 months we've implemented a
type repple and integrated this idea of
using static types to resolve type hints
and
excuse me and the next few things we're
going to tackle are implementing the
language mediator the big yellow line
and how things go back and forth and in
this story with proxies again if you've
got good ideas of how to change a method
call to a final class please find me I
think that's impossible but the last
time I said that about the JVM someone
shouted out challenge accepted anyway so
this is the final goal gradual typing
for closure
it'll probably have its own set of
trade-offs which are interesting for a
gradual gradual typing people kind of
the goals are that it's intuitive to use
for closure programmers really so I just
like to conclude by thanking everyone
who's here and also thanking everyone
who supported me over the years with the
crowdfunding I've been doing it's really
I had a summer over in Australia and
it's one of the reasons why I'm back
here is they're all your support and
it's great to be in the States and
thanks for listening